it's a big part of the culture now
especially with younger people naked
selfies it's I listen I like naked self
or your life away I like go do your
thing but clean your room and I get like
like guys being like well if you had a
penis you wouldn't exactly be looking at
the room I understand that but what I
didn't get that if I had a penis my room
would be clean you know I mean if you
had a penis you wouldn't be thinking
about I see right you're not gonna
notice it I got it
but wouldn't you prefer a clean room a
naked girl in a clean room to a naked
girl in a messy room I'm just saying if
I were a guy I would be seeking out the
neat freaks and asking them for naked
selfies right so you went through all
the trouble to like you know strike the
pose and do the thing make your bed yeah
that's so funny that you're noticing
stuff in the background like that
picture that no that picture clashes
with the wallpaper that comes down that
moves your decorator madam yeah AB
they're wonderful but stop it do you
worry at all about we're in this era now
of cell phone cameras where everywhere
you go people record if you're
especially if you're a known person well
I just accept that you're gonna be
recorded cuz I like to sing in the car
and I have singing in the car rocking
out I have gotten people tweeting at me
like hey girl I see you you're not white
enough to be rocking out to that song I
mean you're not you're too white to be
rocking out to that song right and and
I'm so terrified that like I know you're
awake enough to record me like rocking
out to something embarrassing and put it
online cuz like I know that people see
me because they have tweeted at me
they've tweeted a that's kind of weird
you know it's you're just on the freeway
and someone recognizes you knows that
you're on Twitter but you don't know
them and they say I like what you're
wearing today but I don't like what
you're singing yeah yeah people got
opinions yeah yeah do you get that any
to get people that recognize you and
then tweet at you like hey your outfits
no no no I people I could that once I
did that to Andy no I I mean not too
much not too much I mean if I'm at an
event kind of sometimes today you know
nobody sees me I'm camouflaged alright
no please it's great no I mean the
difference between me walking around and
him walking around is crazy oh well
thank you very much I think the problem
with me is that I look like if I put on
glasses and a hat it looks I've said
this before but it looks like big bird
on Sesame Street put on glasses and a
hat no I just like coke galumphing along
people like there it is we were we did
it we did the show from Chicago and I
you know I walk around and don't get
hassled that much but I went out to
dinner with him and people literally
stopped us in the middle of the street
to say could we take a selfie like well
yeah but how about on the sidewalk you
know but it was just because I've been
hitting any time
you